This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences essential
for accompanying and support the people confronted to the challenges and to find out to service of the community francophone of all the
country. Don't know the health in French, it's possible with the CIT. Visit Collage LAC.C.
D.M.C. a initiative of the initiative National of Formation in Health Souttened by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside
those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveh and DePippo.
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil.
Quarri in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Here. Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed.
And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority of Black City, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of your 20s. This topic has been a long time coming. It has been on my list of
things that I really want to talk about for a while. And today we are finally getting around to doing it. We're going to be talking about the psychology of hobbies and how essential they are, not just for your well-being, but for this decade of life, I think personally, that hobbies are just as important as our friendships during our 20s. But despite that, we really do struggle, you and I, both of us can acknowledge that we struggle to devote the necessary time to them, to doing our hobbies. We wish that we had more kind of things that we love to do in our free time. For me personally, I feel like I collect hobbies almost like their trinkets. Like I have so many hobbies on rotation that I adore and then I love doing, but I don't always get the chance to actually do them and, you know,
I'll drop them every now and again and then pick them back up like six months. later and what I've really begun to realize is that the times when I'm not actively doing my hobbies are the times when my life kind of suffers. Often it's that my life feels like it's all centered on work and my relationships and my responsibilities and we need something deeper than that. We need projects. We need creativity. We need to be using different parts of our brain and there are just so many benefits that hobbies bring. You think that something so small and so playful often and so fun couldn't be so powerful. But I think actually enjoying your life is one of those crucial, you know,
secret parts of being healthier physically, of being more rounded and more interesting, fulfilled person. Hobbies play a big role in that. And it's so easy to see our well-being is like physical health, mental health, seeing friends, but having fun, being creative, doing something else, with your time is significant. I also feel like hobbies are so great for reconnecting with your inner child. They make you feel curious. They're great for connecting with others. They use new parts of your brain that lay dormant whilst you're at work. You know, the list goes on. So today we're
going to talk about the hidden psychological benefits of hobbies that you may not know, the different types of hobbies, different categories of hobbies that are really actually quite fascinating when you get into it and why it is that we struggle so much to get engaged in them. Why it is so much easier to consume, to watch television, to watch Instagram reels, to watch TikToks, why that has become the status quo and how we can overcome the three major barriers that are stopping us from doing our hobbies. I am energized by this episode. I am excited by this episode. I want us all to leave, ready to try something new, to get your hands dirty, to get playful, get active, whatever it is. So without further ado, let's dive into all of the psychology behind why we need hobbies, especially
in our 20s. Let's begin with the basics, something so simple that it might seem silly. What is a hobby? What does that even mean in this day and age? That's where we really have to begin. and it's actually not a stupid question because surprisingly, the very definition of what makes up a hobby is up for debate. I think the debate is actually best summarized by whether you think watching movies is a hobby or not. Because some people say, yes, of course it is.
It's like quite educational. You can get quite intellectual about it. And other people would be like, yeah, absolutely no way. That's way too passive to be a hobby. Think about your answer because it actually points to a really important distinction between what makes up a hobby and what does it. We can all agree that a hobby is something we do with our free time that we naturally enjoy. It also can't be related to work. And some people would even say it can't be related to anything that you need to do, anything that is essential that you need for survival.
So I love grocery shopping, right? And I do that in my free time. but it's not a hobby because it's something that is essential. So hobbies are their own unique form of, you know, leisure that is not purpose driven. The debate I mentioned before is also about whether a hobby requires some kind of effort or energy to be considered a hobby. So there is very little mental effort that goes into being on your phone or scrolling
or watching TV. And so people would say there's not an active commitment. you're not really getting something out because you're not putting anything in. But maybe, you know, foreign films at festivals would count because it does require some kind of cognitive expenditure. Hopefully that makes sense. It's really that debate around what crosses the line. And if you want my opinion, I'm a bit of a hobby traditionalist.
I do think that your hobbies kind of require something extra. They require you to like switch on your brain or your body or your creativity. in a way that, you know, a passive act like watching TV or being on your phone doesn't, like it's active. If you don't agree, obviously, I would love to hear from you because I know that there's differing opinions, but basically it's something that you find fun that you do in your leisure time, that you do regularly, which we'll get to later, and that uses some part of your brain or your body, which is not related to work or something essential. something really fascinating, at least I think it's fascinating, but something fascinating that I
discovered is about how certain people think about hobbies, especially sociologists, and how they group them. So there are actually three different types of hobbies or hobbyists, people who do hobbies. According to this book, which is a whole book on the psychology and the sociology of hobbies published in 2015, There is the casual leisure kind of hobby that is fun, you know, maybe short-lived, doesn't really require a lot of preparation or money. So, like, you might go and play basketball at a community court once a week or you swim at a local pool. You play board games. You make some kind of art, like, coloring in.
That is casual leisure. Then we get a bit more serious. And this is very properly called serious leisure. hobbies. These are the kinds of hobbies that require a bit more effort, a bit more money as well to be rewarding. Like ceramics, there is, you do have to pay for the tools, you have to pay for the equipment or horse riding or scuba diving. It can also describe people who have taken a casual leisure hobby, so like bike riding and made it a lot more serious. You know, you can get a $50 secondhand bike on Facebook marketplace and like ride it around your neighborhood and that can be a hobby.
Or for example, you know, I have a friend Felix who spends so much money on bikes and equipment and he does races and he has gels and outfits. Like, you know, he's at that serious leisure level. I'm going to make an argument that even like a hobby like reading can become serious leisure and we're seeing that more with like the popularity of book talk where like people build whole rooms for their books. They collect them. They have these long-term yearly reading goals of like 100, 200 books. Like that has to cost money. And I was speaking to a friend about this recently who was saying, and she's like a huge avid reader. And she was saying how that culture has really
taken the fun out of reading and like and the fun of book clubs and of the community because it's not leisure anymore. It's almost like work. It's almost like competition amongst other people in the community. Just a quick sidebar. I thought that was very interesting. But finally, we have project-based leisure. That's our final category. And this is short term. It's often one-off projects that are rewarding, like building Lego sets, volunteering for sports events or like building a really elaborate garden. You know, you just, you can't do that every day. You might only do it like three to four times a year. But it is still like an ongoing project. project-based hobby. So that brings us to another fascinating debate. How many hobbies should you have
and how often should you be doing them? This definitely like varies on age. I feel like we all have the experience of being a kid or a teenager and having seemingly like thousands of hobbies that are then replaced by work and replaced by like the other things that we need to do. do day in and day out as we get older. But then I think as we reach like an older age, almost becoming elderly, all of our hobbies come back. And I'm going to use the example of my grandma as a prime opportunity to explain this. That woman is so busy. She is bustling. She is doing. She gardens. She paints. Volunteers. She reads, breaks, go to the gym, even like 78. So it's kind of like it definitely differs across our lifespan.
But if we are following the law of averages, researchers will typically say that two to five hobbies is the sweet spot. You should have between two to five things that you're really passionate about and then maybe a few other things that you do, you know, occasionally. So one study from 2010 that was actually the first of its kind, it basically tried to find the golden number for hobbies. And fascinatingly, interestingly, shockingly, they found that the limit does not exist. As long as you have the space and the time, the more hobbies you do, the more improvements
you will see to your physical and psychological health. It's also associated with less stress, lower blood pressure. That's what having more hobbies. and more leisure time brings you. I think the more leisure time is also an important factor. These are all things that, you know, we really want to say. So basically, as long as you have the space, you can have as many hobbies as you want and still be benefiting.
There is another formula that you've probably heard as well, another like golden number for hobbies. And that is the formula of four. We need four hobbies. A hobby to keep you physically fit. a hobby to stay creative, a hobby to stay mentally fit, and a hobby to make money. I tried so hard to like try and figure out who said this first. I think nowadays it's just common wisdom and I love the first three. My hobby to keep me fit is boxing in the gym and then I do ceramics to stay creative and I read and I listen to
podcasts. I read journals to like keep myself mentally fit. But the last one, a hobby to make you money. I do have a small issue with including that because I think when you make money from a hobby, you lose the implicit natural enjoyment that is meant to bring. And I actually say that as someone who made one of their hobbies like a full-time job, you know, this podcast used to be purely a leisure activity. I posted what I wanted, not as frequently as I do now. It was just super random topics that I'd cover and I literally have my friends on as guests and then a lot of you tuned in. Thank you for doing that. And it became my full-time job.
This is what I want to say about that. And I want to caveat by saying, I absolutely love what I do. But when you start doing the thing that you used to do purely for enjoyment as a way to make money, you have got to love it at least like 200%. Because when money and finances get involved, it is naturally going to become stressful and you will lose, I would like to say, 100% of the love. So you have to be at a 200% level to afford to lose 100% of the love so that you're still full of passion for it. So you've, you know, you've still got to make sure you have that motivation. You're naturally going to lose that
when it becomes a job. And it's really, really common that this happens, especially amongst people who are creators or musicians or people who are sports people. Athletes. I love that I didn't know the word for that. Athletes. For me, I, you know, I had like basically a hobby crisis when the podcast became my full-time job like almost two years ago now because it was all I cared about. It was all I cared about. It was the thing I really loved doing. And then it became additionally my source of financial security or lack thereof. And it made it pretty exhausting because additionally I think nothing had taken its place in my life as the thing that I just purely did for the pleasure of it. There was nothing leisure-based that I was doing
outside of this because it was taking a while for everything to kind of line up or kind of settle into place and that is when I think I had this whole crisis of like who am I? What do I even stand for that isn't work and I made it a real thing that I was dedicating myself to. I was dedicating myself to my hobbies. I started pottery. I started swimming in the ocean again. I started boxing because I didn't want to lose myself any further in that process. So why do we need to do this? Why do we need to spend time, devote time, prioritize time for our hobbies? And speaking from a psychological, emotional, even physical perspective, what are the benefits? We are going to talk about all of that and more after this short break.
I'm going to hold your hand when I say this, but your life will never be truly fulfilling if all you have is work and your relationships. Both of those things are really crucial, but you need something that's just about you. You need more flavor. You need more excitement. That is what hobbies are for. Especially in our 20s, there is this very important developmental transition we experience where work becomes the predominant activity in our lives. And naturally it takes over a lot of our identity.
And that makes sense. If you're spending eight hours plus at your job every day, that is a big chunk of your time that it's going to be consumed with whatever it is you're doing, data entry, talking to people, solving problems, helping people moving things, whatever it is. There was a really great article from Yale University that spoke about how, This is particularly a problem for those of us who are relatively early on in our careers because there's that implicit fear of failure that drives us to center our lives on work
and achieving what is expected of us. This intense drive and focus, it forces our identity to ultimately become synonymous with what we do for a living. I remember when I was working as a consultant, like someone asked me like two years into working this job. What do you do for fun? And I had to really think about it and then I had to make it up because at that point, work was everything to me. Yes, I would like see my friends. I would go out for drinks. I would go out for dinner. I'd go to the gym. But there wasn't much more. There wasn't much that was individual to me. And that is a big risk of not having hobbies. You stop being someone who has
dimension. And that brings me to a huge benefit. Having a hobby, having a couple allows you to build an intentional life outside of career and outside your work. Think of yourself and your life as like containing five buckets. You have your relationships, you have your work, your well-being, personal growth, and then you have fun. You have leisure. Your way to a balanced life is to pour as equally as you can into each of these buckets. But you kind of never get more water. So at any given time, the amount of water you have to distribute across all these things is going to be the same. You can pour from one bucket into another. You can empty a bucket. But when these buckets are uneven, we suffer. If you keep pouring into the work bucket, you have to pour from the health bucket. You have to
pour from the personal growth bucket, from your leisure bucket, your relationships will suffer. By having those hobbies that we enjoy and make time for, we balance out all the other buckets. We make sure that no one bucket ever gets too big that it consumes all the liquid, all the water, all the energy. One study, for example, looked at the relationship between when you work really long hours and how that impacts depression and well-being. And on top of discovering the very obvious thing, which is that the more hours you work, the more significant negative impact it has on your health, what researchers did find was that having hobbies, even if you had limited time, actually helped mitigate those adverse side effects because you were still putting time, energy, you were making
an investment in yourself as someone who was not just, an employee. You know, you had this place to go where your brain can think about something different. It can de-stress. It can compartmentalize. That's also why I really often say that your hobbies should be different to what you do at work all day. You know, like if you're a nurse, your hobby, this is going to sound slightly, but it can't be like playing operation. You know, that's a silly example. But if you spend your day working in front of a screen doing like data or like marketing or whatever, you know, it's not great if you come home and you have more screen-based hobbies. You want it to be quite nuanced.
You want to give your brain something more to play with. You know, hobbies also just simply make you happier. We're just going to say it from the most basic psychological lens. When you participate in something you love, your brain rewards you with dopamine. That keeps you motivated to keep going. It makes you happier. A life filled with hobbies feels more. purposeful. One of my favorite, favorite, favorite pieces of research that supports this was
conducted with almost, and I'm going to say this number because it's astounding, 100,000 people. That's right. It was a piece of research on 100,000 people, all of them over the age of 65, and they'd all retired. And what they found was that when these older adults had hobbies and they did their hobby more than once a week, they not only were happier, they also lived longer because health is not just physical. It is mental. It is cognitive. You will start giving up on your physical health. You will start not caring about yourself as much if you don't have something that you actually want to live for, something that you actually enjoy doing. You won't feel as positive towards yourself. You won't feel as positive towards your well-being and as active and protective if you don't feel like you have a purpose.
if you're not happy. And, you know, we don't need, like, a study to tell us that, like, intuitively humans need recreational time. They need things to care about. But I do think it's really important that I remind you. I'm just going to rattle off some other benefits. I know I've probably convinced you by now, but just quickly. Hobbies improve your focus. You know, even if you think, I don't have time for this, I'm so busy with work or school, like, I'm not going to do my hobbies. I'm not going to go for a swim and not going to go to the gym and not going to do this, that, whatever. Actually, setting aside time to do those things will mean that you perform better anyways. They make you less stressed. They make you more in touch with your authentic self.
And like depending on whether the activity is solo or group based as well, it can make you less lonely. It's a valuable part of our routine. It makes us more flexible. Every single thing, points to us needing more time to do this. Scary finding, though, from the last few years is that this generation, you know, you and me, people born after 1995, we are not picking up hobbies the same way people used to. We're seeing a steady decline in hobbyists, the people who have a lot of hobbies, who make hobbies a part of who they are. And a lot of our hobbies are based on consumption.
So they are based on watching TV. They are based on collecting things that we have to buy, shopping, video games, movies, rather than production-based hobbies, production-based activities, things that are about creating something new, expressing yourself, expending energy, giving something back. And it's not to say that certain hobbies are better or worse than others or, like, more pure. but I think if all our activities are attached to consumption and spending money, you know, it doesn't feel as fruitful. You don't actually feel like you're connecting in the same way with what you're doing. This probably comes down to a few things like this whole trend. Obviously, like the rise in technology is one of them.
Like that is just what we are being fed. Screens are always at hand, always available. I don't think that they're like the devil. that we think they are. I think they're actually really important. But, you know, our way of entertaining ourselves has shifted online. I also think we are busier than ever. We have more commitments. We spend more time at work. There is less community feel to our hobbies. This really sticks out to me. I think that people are craving in-person activities and community-building, especially after the pandemic because everything that we were doing became so solitary,
meaning that we don't have the same social motivation to do them. It is why, personal opinion, book clubs, meetups, social sports, so special, but also so much more popular. I want to talk about how we can make our hobbies a priority, even in our busy lives, even when we're burnt out, even when it's so much easier to like turn on the team. or scroll on TikTok, how do we find the time? How do we make the time more importantly? We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. I want you to pause for a second and ask yourself an important question. How many hobbies do you actually have? Like that you regularly do
more than once a fortnight and how often are you actually doing them? A lot of us might come up with a few things. maybe nothing. I think that is the major problem we're facing here. We like to think that we're doing our hobbies, but actually they tend to fall of our prioritization, our to-do list. Something I've seen a lot recently is like, even within myself, being like, oh yeah, I love reading, I love hiking, I love rock climbing. And then you go back through your recent memories and you're like, I can't actually remember the last time I did those things. Can't remember when I last finished a book, when I went on a nice hike for the weekend. I think it comes down to three major problems. Firstly, there is a genuine lack of time. You know, life is really busy at the moment.
We've got places to go. We've got people to see. A lot of us are embracing hustle culture and when there always seems to be something more urgent to do, you just don't have the same capacity time-wise for your hobbies. That's problem one, a very serious problem. Problem two is that we just think we don't have enough time. But actually we do, we just don't have the motivation. Number two, a lack of motivation. This is often linked to procrastination, which we know can also come down to perfectionism. Like, I can't do my hobbies because I'm not as good as other people are. I'm not as good as the people I see in the studio, online at the gym. That's what gets in our way. Or we just don't prioritize our hobbies because there is something easy.
to do something easier that we want to do, like maybe scroll on our phones, whatever, that gives us that instant dopamine and that instant gratification, whereas pursuing our hobbies takes more of a time investment to get the reward. You may start out your night, like wanting to do some painting or like wanting to do something fun, but then pretty soon you get pulled in by your phone, it's 10pm, it's time for bed. That is a really common dilemma. Something interesting that I found in some research conducted in the UK a few years ago is that our failure to do our hobbies is actually a cycle that comes back to motivational fatigue or a motivational
deficit whereby our hobbies would actually motivate us to do them more, but the more we don't do them, the less motivated we become. So really the hardest step when you've fallen off your hobbies, is when you've stopped doing them. The hardest step is the first one. You know, just doing the thing. Just committing, despite all the other distractions, that is where you're going to struggle the most. But then you get the motivation.
You get the wheel rolling again. I think that's like any habit. It's always hard at the beginning. Like the first five minutes of a run, the first hour of starting an assignment. There is just like so much time ahead of you. It just feels so long. But then you get going.
It becomes more enjoyable. That is the motivational. process of doing your hobbies more regularly. Finally, it may be that actually those hobbies that you've fallen away from, they just aren't fun anymore. They're just not something that you want to do. We're not particularly keen on doing them. I remember trying so hard to like be into rock climbing back in the day and like make that my new hobby. I even had like the shoes and everything. I just couldn't force it. I couldn't do it. It was like trying to fit into the wrong relationship. I think at those points, obviously you're not going to want to participate, but you still have this like almost hypothetical, like fake faux idea in your mind that that is still an active hobby for you when you haven't done it in like years, maybe even months.
Maybe it's time to start something new. Maybe it's time to refresh the hobby roster. And that brings me to the final reason that you're not doing your hobbies. It's because you're not excited about them. because you lack inspiration. Let's address that issue first, because I actually think that is the biggest culprit of all these reasons. I want to give you some ideas of some hobbies that you maybe haven't considered.
I think we're all pretty used to the basic hobbies that people will list. And if you're not really into running or reading, sometimes it's like, well, kind of what else is out there, but fear not. There are so many other things out there. I want to give you some of that inspiration you might be lacking. You could go shell collecting. Maybe your hobby is to go to the beach once a week, have a swim and find some shells and make cool jewelry out of them. Like make cool ceramic dishes using the shells.
我想我们对人们列出的那些基本爱好都已经习以为常了。如果你真的不怎么喜欢跑步或阅读，有时就会觉得，好吧，那外面还有什么别的呢？不过别担心，外面还有那么多其他的事情。我想给你提供一些你可能缺乏的灵感。你可以去收集贝壳。也许你的爱好是每周去一次海滩，游个泳，找一些贝壳，用它们制作酷炫的首饰。比如用贝壳制作很棒的陶瓷盘子。
Baking for a new person each week. I was really into this a few years ago. Like each week, I would choose someone new like my neighbors, my roommates, some person I was going over to have dinner with and I would make a new recipe for them. join a social sport team that like plays a new sport every week. I used to do this last year. It was super, super fun. Letter writing, you could make like really beautiful letters for your family or like your internet friends or like your long distance college friends and send them back and forth. Hosting, you could host like a little dinner party every Sunday as like your hobby is literally hosting. Like your hobby is to create nice events for people to come and like hang out together.
每周为新的一个人烤面包。几年前我真的很迷这个。就像每周我都会选择一个新的人，比如我的邻居、我的室友、某个我要去他家吃晚饭的人，然后为他们做一个新食谱。加入一个社交运动队，每周玩一项新运动。我去年经常这样做。真的超级超级有趣。写信，你可以为你的家人、网上的朋友或者异地的大学朋友写非常漂亮的信，然后寄来寄去。举办聚会，你可以每个星期天举办一个小晚宴，你的爱好 literalmente 就是举办聚会。就像你的爱好是为人们创造美好的活动，让他们聚在一起聊天。
Make a little veggie pack. or a garden that you tend to or a bonsai tree, go to a ceramics class. I'm doing this currently. Actually, I've done three now and they're all like six weeks long. So you have to keep going because you pay at the beginning and you've committed knitting. This is one of my favorites. It sounds so like grandma core. But when you get into it, you can like sit and listen to a podcast and just get so stuck into it.
做一个小菜园，或者一个你精心照料的花园，或者一盆盆景，去上陶瓷课。我目前正在做这个。实际上，我已经上了三节课了，每节课大约持续六周。所以你必须坚持下去，因为你在一开始就付了钱，而且你已经承诺了。织毛织品。这是我最喜欢的活动之一。这听起来太像“老奶奶风”了。但当你真正投入进去时，你可以坐下来听播客，然后完全沉浸其中。
There's also people who like upcycle, which I love. that's something that me and my boyfriend Tom do, like once a week. We might go for a little walk around our neighbourhood. Maybe this is just like an Australian thing, but people leave stuff out on the street all the time for like people to take with like little notes. So they'll have like, you know, everyone will have like a little box of stuff that people put things in. And I don't know, it's just some people call it garbage. I think it's treasure.
也有人喜欢进行旧物改造，我超级喜欢。这也是我和我男朋友汤姆每周大约做一次的事情。我们可能会在我们的街区周围散步。也许这只是澳大利亚的某种特色，但人们总是把东西留在街上，让人拿走，并附上小纸条。所以他们会有，你知道的，每个人都会有一个装着东西的小盒子，供别人取用。我不知道，有些人称之为垃圾。我认为那是宝藏。
You know, you could start a podcast just like documenting your life and learning. how to do all the sound editing and the uploading and the publishing and just not even tell anyone it's just going to be like your own personal audio journal there is just so much out there that's really what i want to remind you there is a lot that you can do you might just need to invest a little bit of time to get things off the ground and to feel excited by it and that kind of brings me to my next barrier which is a lack of motivation this is probably the hardest one to overcome if a lack of inspiration is the most common, a lack of motivation is the hardest. I think if you're in this position, you need to treat the next month as like an exploration phase for you. So like set a personal
你知道的，你可以创办一个播客，用来记录你的生活和学习过程，比如所有的音频剪辑、上传和发布，甚至不用告诉任何人，它就像是你自己的个人音频日记。外面有太多的东西可以去探索，这正是我想要提醒大家的。有很多事情你可以做，你可能只需要投入一点点时间让事情步入正轨，并从中感受到兴奋。这就引出了我的下一个障碍，也就是缺乏动力。如果缺乏灵感是最常见的，那么缺乏动力就是最难克服的。我想如果你处于这种状态，你需要把接下来的一个月当作你的探索阶段。所以，设定一个个人的
challenge, set a goal to just try heaps of new things, even if you don't have high expectations. Make it like a way to socialize. Like instead of drinks, go and like get a jewelry making set or like go and get a puzzle, do a board game's night at a pub. go for a hike. You don't have to commit to anything. All you're required to do is to have a taste, is to just have a little palate cleanse, is to just fill your days with activities rather than just lounging passive consumption. On another note, returning to your old hobbies often does start with just remembering why they brought you so much joy in the first place. We can forget that. It's very easy to lose touch with the things you love when life gets busy or when other priorities take over.
挑战，设定一个目标，去尝试大量的新事物，即使你没有太高的期望。把它当作一种社交方式。比如，不要去喝酒，而是去买一套做首饰的材料，或者去买一个拼图，在酒吧里办一个桌游之夜，去远足。你不需要承诺任何事情。你所需要做的只是去尝尝鲜，就像给味蕾做个清爽的缓冲，让你的活动充满每一天，而不是仅仅躺在那里被动地消费。从另一方面来说，重新开始你旧的爱好，通常只需要记住它们最初为什么给你带来那么多的快乐。我们可能会忘记这一点。当生活变得忙碌或者其他优先事项占据主导地位时，很容易与你热爱的事物失去联系。
But hobbies are a form of self-care. Think about how great you always feel afterwards. Even if you have to kind of like mentally drag yourself to the starting line, be like, okay, I'm going to let myself watch TV in 20 minutes. But before I do that, the same way that I make time to exercise. I make time to clean my house. I make time to talk to my friends. I'm going to make time to do my hobbies as a part of my hygiene routine as a part of my wellness routine. This, look at this perfect segue into talking about a lack of time because that is another big conundrum, another big problem that we hear a lot. I hate to say it and I'm going to be very gentle when I say it, but we can always make time for what we care about. And just to prove that,
但爱好是一种自我关爱。想想你事后总是感觉多棒。即使你不得不像在精神上把自己拖到起跑线一样，告诉自己：好吧，我允许自己在20分钟后看电视。但在那之前，就像我腾出时间锻炼一样。我腾出时间打扫房子。我腾出时间与朋友交谈。我要腾出时间做我的爱好，作为我的个人卫生常规的一部分，作为我的健康常规的一部分。看，这是一个完美的过渡，谈谈缺乏时间的问题，因为这是另一个巨大的难题，另一个我们经常听到的大问题。我讨厌这么说，而且我会非常温和地说，但我们总能为我们在乎的事抽出时间。为了证明这一点，
I want you to just think about your screen time for a second. How many 10, 20 minute increments do we have each day that instead we spend scrolling or watching? You know, you could switch that up. You could make time for something else, even if it's small, even if it doesn't initially feel significant. Think about like when you're on the train. I saw this woman the other day. I saw this woman the other day. knitting. She was only on for like four stops, but she pulled out her knitting needles and she was making, I don't really know what she was making. It looked really, really amazing though. You could bring your book and your goal for the next month is to, instead of go on your phone on your 20 minute commute on the bus or on the train, is to read. Try and find small pockets of time just because it doesn't feel like
我想让你花一秒钟想想你的屏幕时间。我们每天有多少个10分钟、20分钟的碎片时间，却花在了刷手机或看视频上？你知道的，你可以改变这种状况。你可以为其他事情腾出时间，即使它很小，即使它最初看起来并不重要。想想你在火车上的时候。我前几天看到一个女人。我前几天看到一个女人在织毛衣。她只坐了四站路，但她拿出了织针，在织着什么，我真的不知道她在织什么。不过看起来真的很棒。你可以带上你的书，你接下来一个月的目标是，在坐公交车或火车的20分钟通勤路上，不要玩手机，而是去读书。试着寻找时间的碎片，仅仅因为感觉不到
it's an extended hour or two hours. Doesn't mean that it's not a significant investment. because the habit is really being built. I also think try and reframe the activity, not as an obligation, but as like something that you have the privilege of doing, something you want to do. It's a chance to unwind. It's a chance to explore. It's a chance to have real fun, like real true enjoyment,
它是一段延长的一个小时或两个小时，并不意味着它不是一个重要的投资。因为习惯真的是在这样建立的。我也认为，试着重新构建这项活动，不要把它当作一种义务，而是当作你有特权去做的事情，当作你想做的事情。这是一个放松的机会。这是一个探索的机会。这是一个真正享受乐趣的机会，真正的快乐，
taking real true enjoyment from something that you're doing. And you'll notice like when you fall asleep at the end of the day, you're like, wow, it just feels so much more fulfilled. because I didn't do what was easiest. I did what I knew was going to fill my cup the most, which was my hobbies. You can notice that change. Give yourself just 30 minutes a day to prioritize this. Even if it's not on all days, you're allowed to obviously have breaks.
从你正在做的事情中获得真正纯粹的快乐。你会注意到，当你一天结束时入睡时，你会想，哇，我感觉充实多了。因为我没有做最简单的事。我做了我知道最能滋养我的事，那就是我的爱好。你能注意到这种变化。每天给自己30分钟的时间来优先处理这件事。即使不是每天都这样，你显然也可以休息。
We can't all be disciplined with new habits. But ask yourself, at the end of the day when you've tried these things, do I feel better? Do I feel better? and the days that I have the time but I choose not to do them, am I going to feel worse? And is that something that I've kind of allowed myself to feel? Knowing that I could have done something that was going to make me feel more energized and inspired and happier, choosing not to do that.
我们不可能对新习惯都那么自律。但问问自己，在一天结束时，当你尝试了这些事情之后，我感觉好点了吗？我感觉好点了吗？在我有时间却选择不做它们的那些日子里，我会感觉更糟糕吗？这也是我某种程度上纵容自己去感受的吗？明知自己本可以做一些让自己感到更有活力、更有灵感、更快乐的事情，却选择不做。
That was a choice I made and I could make a different choice next time. I could do something that actually fills my cup, makes me interested, makes me interesting, like makes me happy, fulfilled, someone who has. has nuance, someone who has dimension to them, who isn't just work and responsibility. So I do know it's really, really hard. I'm saying this to someone who's definitely struggled with this as I've gotten older. There's just less pieces of the pie to give out. And it's always like a, it's always like a balancing act of like what part of my life, what bucket is going to get more from me. But I do think that this is the bucket we should be pouring more into than we actually are. Hobbies
那是我做出的选择，我下次可以做出不同的选择。我可以做一些真正滋养我、让我感兴趣、让我变得有趣的事情，比如让我快乐、充实、成为一个有深度、有维度的人，而不仅仅是工作和责任。所以我知道这真的非常非常难。我对一个随着年龄增长也一直在与此斗争的人说这些。人生这块蛋糕可以分出去的份额变少了。这总是一个平衡的艺术，关乎我生活的哪一部分、哪一个领域会从我这里得到更多。但我确实认为，这是我们应该投入更多心力的领域，超出我们的实际投入。爱好
are spectacular. They're amazing. They're so valuable for your 20s. So I just hope this has inspired you to get back into something that used to bring you a lot of joy and a lot of freedom and that you just really love doing, whether it's music, sport, art, whatever it is. Find a way back to it. See how your life improves. Hopefully you enjoyed this episode. If you did, please, feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. I say it every time, but it does help the show grow, meet new people, reach new people, sorry, and I do read every single one of your reviews. They often end up in my little smile file. They're often the thing that I feel very grateful for at the end of the day. So thank you for
简直棒极了。它们太惊艳了，对你的20多岁非常有价值。所以我只希望这能激励你重新找回那些曾经带给你许多快乐和自由、并且你真心热爱的事物，无论是音乐、运动、艺术，还是别的什么。找到通往它的路。看看你的生活是如何改善的。希望你喜欢这一集。如果你喜欢，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。我每次都这么说，但这确实有助于节目成长，结识新朋友，触达更多新朋友，抱歉，而且我确实会阅读你们的每一条评论。它们经常出现在我的“微笑文件”中。它们通常是让我一天结束时感到非常感激的事情。所以谢谢你们的支持
the support if you have done so already. If you have an episode suggestion, questions, follow-ups to this episode, you can DM me at that psychology podcast. We would love to hear from you as always. And until next week, stay safe. Be kind. Be good. gentle with yourself and we will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. People wake up.
如果你已经这样做了。如果你有节目建议、问题、对本节目的后续反馈，你可以在“that psychology podcast”私信我。一如既往，我们非常乐意听到你的声音。直到下周，注意安全。保持善良。对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变黑了。把我吓坏了。人们醒醒吧。
I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Crevecette and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence.
我是那个在克雷韦塞特和德皮波看到谋杀发生的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说我没有罪。我要把它带进坟墓。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方，收听“魔鬼采石场”之“骨头谷”节目。快乐至关重要，它也难以捉摸，但现在有一个令人兴奋的新方法来开始你迈向更快乐生活的旅程。
Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, How to Copy. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born.
乔伊101。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中聊天。打开你的免费IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Joy 101”并立即收听。由CVS呈现的由霍达·科特比主持的Joy 101。每个人都把我当成一个足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存，自从我出生以来。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot Hernandez and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media. Weedian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created the show why I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast,
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查利托·埃尔南德斯，在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“学习做人”。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个整体。“无家可归者的声音”是一个正在改变这种叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，我在洛杉矶的街头创立了这个节目——为什么我无家可归。我们已经成长为一个两度获得韦比奖的播客，
the only podcast that shares Un-House stories and news from the Un-House perspective. Listen to Wey and Howls on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is. Getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit, Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority of black city, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there.
唯一一个分享无家可归者故事和来自无家可归者视角的新闻的播客。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“无家可归者的声音”。这里有一件事本不该如此复杂：移除一个种族主义者的雕像。这里还有一件事本应该容易得多：在原地竖起一个新雕像。我是阿凯拉·休斯，“反叛精神”第二季就关于这两件事。当我看着这些雕像倒塌时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里的奴役者纪念碑比……
word to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit season two on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
……对被奴役的人的纪念碑还要多，这意味着什么。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“反叛精神”第二季。这是一个IHeart播客。保证人类制作。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。